despite an increase in demand for covid
test the health district says results
should still only take a few days the
demand for testing is up about 60
percent joe moller joining us live
outside the health district near the 95
in decatur for just how long it could
take joe
with more gatherings happening right now
during the holidays more people are
looking to get tested today i spoke to
an official here at the southern nevada
health district and they tell me they
are trying to get you your results as
fast as they can
as omicron concerns linger more people
are trying to make sure they don't
spread the virus last week the health
district conducted 8 000 tests at just
its sites that's up 3 000 tests from the
week before after getting tested some
people are getting messages like this
stating results could take seven days
but the health district told me they are
turning results in about 48 hours still
many testing companies are noticing the
increase amanda ellis from e-7 testing
clinic says they are also seeing more
people there's definitely at least a 50
increase that we've seen recently with
demand for pcr testing with the holidays
and also with the variant happening
there are a lot of people that want to
make sure that they're tested for small
gatherings she says their pcr testing
results can be done in about an hour
which is why so many people flying out
of the country are going to them
ella says with the holiday long holiday
weekend that is she expects even more
people to get tested this weekend and
even next week reporting outside the
health district joe mulder live local
now